[Music]
Clank maybe get this whole thing right
here okay this whole this mural with the
shark I need that I need to come down
and land right here and action all right
so red this is gonna be an effect shot
where your character dries sir that's a
nice angle try to beat it so I can try
to overcompensate with your three two
one action
I am testing out to see if our backup
Germany is working well we had a little
mishap of the first one is the main bad
guy and he wasn't working
that's not really
a good thing for the video will it work
that's the question
might seem on paper oh my god
cuz we were kind of art department on
the drones we glued stuff to them and
repainted them and I worked mostly on
the judge dredd drone and his two
cronies which you will see they have
spiky wheels and helmets and
things pretty fun and wacky one of the
weirdest things that are done for court
over probably you guys are gonna be on
the drones here Jojo it's gonna be in
place
it's gonna roll and you're just gonna
happen you guys are all roll off
together okay yeah technology issues are
the bane of our existence
we're shooting a bunch of stuff here in
the alleyway and then this truck driver
came in [ __ ] right in our shot how do
we change what we find out you go there
got it so what's going on right now with
this guy it's raining dare to shoot
why is it raining
take a break right now a little bit too
hot to dry so
different plans
what is
what we just did with the jumping is a
perfect stopping point because then we
just cut to the shot of drones red going
through the box and then it's just one
more swerving shot which we can get to
skip tomorrow and then we'll go to the
other location with the stairs so
yesterday this place was an entire River
as evidenced by photo imagery and now
it's actually pretty dry I was not
confident that I would be I thought
there's no way that water was gonna be
gone but sure enough California is also
like a dry sponge just soaked up all the
water it was like give me more I'm so
thirsty
lorilynn today Steve this works you try
one going forward Nick okay let's go
Michael you guys ready
[Music]
let's do okay let's get this this is the
last four watching we hope you learned
something see you next week